Hello, my name is Zisl Slepovitch
and I'm musician-in-residence at Yale
University's Fortunoff Video Archive for
Holocaust Testimonies.
This video series is designed as a companion
to our album Where Is Our Homeland,
which is the first volume in the archives
ongoing effort to present songs
and poems performed by survivors in testimonies
given to the Fortunoff Archive over
the last 40 years.
You can learn more about the project on the
Archives website, songsfromtestimonies.org.
Where Is Our Homeland?
Songs from Testimonies.
Volume One was recorded in 2019
by the Zisl Slepovitch Ensemble featuring
renowned singer Sasha Lurje,
Craig Judelman on the violin, Joshua
Camp on the accordion, keyboards and guitar,
Dmitry Ishenko on the bass, and myself
on woodwinds.
The songs in this collection differ vastly in
terms of style, social and historical
background, language, and many other aspects,
but collectively they create a multidimensional
picture of Jewish life before
and during World War Two.
Irene S. was born in 1925
in Brzezany or Berezhany, in Galicia,
now in Ukraine, and was raised in Grudziadz,
Poland.
Irene was the prisoner of the Bialystok ghetto
and later of several concentration camps,
including Majdanek, Treblinka, and
Auschwitz.
Irene was a slave laborer in Germany and
was liberated by the Americans in Kaunitz.
By the time the war broke out, Irene was an
accomplished singer-songwriter.
In her testimony, she recalls singing
existing songs and composing new ones
together with her young fellow prisoners from
Poland and the Soviet Union.
While Irene's native language was Polish,
she co-wrote this song with a Russian
speaking boy as they were transported from
Bialystok Ghetto to Majdanek, by the
way of Treblinka.
The song Manifesto of the Enslaved Children
was created in the genre of the heroic military
march in the minor key, which was
quite typical for the protest and resistance
songs of the era.
It's, uh.
Oh, I don't know if I could sing it
now.
Just try.
Thunderstorms of war embrace the world,
And the workers’ blood is flowing.
We, yesterday’s children of freedom,
Are today’s tribe of slaves.
Just a verse, and--
What does it mean?
This is in Russian that uh,
a world wide
storm is embracing this world.
And, uh,
people's blood is being shed all, all over.
And yesterday's free children
were today's.
Were today's
war prisoners, prisoners of war,
or today's slaves, really.
The best translation is, today we
are a bunch of slaves.
And it goes on.
We are broke-- we are
kept apart from the rest of the world and
locked in this ghetto.
And we are beaten with the
Nazi
stick.
But if today life was bad for
us, we are still hoping for a better
tomorrow. Well, all of
those songs were always
like this.
Can you sing that part about the hope
that you had?
Locked up in the ghetto,
torn from the world,
Lashed with the Nazi whip.
But if today is hard and miserable,
We will wait for tomorrow;
If today is hard and miserable,
We will wait for a better tomorrow.
The reason for it was written in Russian
was that the boy who wrote the words didn't
speak Yiddish and so we had
a choice of Polish or Russian.
So we wrote it in Russian.
Thunderstorms of war embrace the world,
And the workers’ blood is flowing.
We, yesterday’s children of freedom,
Are today’s tribe of slaves.
Locked up in the ghetto,
torn from the world,
Lashed with the Nazi whip.
But if today is hard and miserable,
We will wait for tomorrow;
If today is hard and miserable,
We will wait for a better tomorrow.
Many people, when they think
of the ghettos in Eastern Europe,
mistakenly regard them
as being only
holding pens for the
death camps or antechambers
to the concentration camps.
But in fact, these ghettos
were still communities
in their own right.
On the one hand,
they were still shaped to
some degree or other by prewar values,
by prewar memories, by
prewar social customs and relationships.
And on the other hand, they were
dealing with unprecedented
oppression.
Now, in the prewar communities,
the Jews had newspapers, they
had radio.
In the ghettos, access
to these forms of social interaction
and communication were terribly limited.
And what took their place
to a very large degree
were songs.
And singing became a basic,
a medium,
a basic type
of ghetto interaction.
Street singers were very popular,
just take a look at Jankele Herszkowicz
in the Lodz ghetto.
People sang together.
Singing together expressed
hopes, fears.
They express the trauma of loss.
If you lost a child or a husband,
a song could
not only express your own
injury, your own hurt,
but the people who were singing
that song with you let you
know that they've suffered the
same loss and they
are experiencing what you're
experiencing.
One of the key features of ghetto
life was the constant
contraction of the distance
between the individual
and the collective.
What happens to me in the ghetto
will probably happen to us
and what happens to us
will probably happen to me.
There were different kinds of ghetto
songs.
One very common
kind of ghetto song was
the inverted prewar
lullaby or folk song,
a tune that everybody
knew, a lullaby that everybody
remembered, would be sung,
but with different words expressing
the stark contrast between
the before and the now.
A lullaby like "Rozinkes Mit
Mandlen," "Raisins and Almonds,"
which mothers would sing to their children,
hoping that they would grow up
to be not only learned in Torah,
but a proficient and wealthy merchant.
Lullabies which talk about how Daddy
is going to come home and he is going
to bring gifts for all of us.
These words were now changed
to express the fact that what
what we have now is,
is, is absolutely different
from what we used to have.
In one lullaby in the Lodz
ghetto, the words are
"nisht keyn rozinkes nisht keyn mandeln
tumbling der tate iz nisht gefarn handeln."
"We don't have raisins, we don't
have almonds.
Our father did not go out to trade.
In fact, our father is gone.
We may never see him again." So
this was one kind of ghetto song.
Then there were beggar songs in
the Warsaw Ghetto.
For example, "ikh, ikh gib nisht ab
di bone," "I'm not giving up my ration
card, I want to survive."
There were parodies,
sarcastic criticisms
of the Judenrat and the Jewish police.
In the Vilna ghetto especially,
many of the songs were connected
to the cabaret and the theater.
The Vilna Ghetto was, had many
gifted song writers like
Kasriel Broyde and Leyb Rozental.
And the Cabaret,
the Ghetto Theater were very, very popular
and some of these songs
were very quickly picked up by everybody.
A song like "Moyshe, halt zikh," sung
to an American ragtime beat, expressing
the hope that you've got to get out of
here. It's going to change.
Just hold on.
Don't get depressed.
A song like "Pesha fon Resha,"
Pesha's a 17 year old girl.
She's lost her parents, but
she's not going to give up hope.
She can find her way
any, anywhere.
She's not going to let herself
get depressed.
There's a song, Yis, "Yisrolek,"
about a tough little kid who's lost
his mommy and daddy.
But nonetheless, nobody's
going to push him around.
And then finally, we have
the kind of song that Irene
Shapiro wrote, these are what
I would call part of the general
genre of partisan songs.
They radiate defiance
and resistance.
They stress the con, the
contrast between the
ghetto today and a
better life tomorrow.
These are not songs of despair
or, or nostalgia.
They're not particularly Jewish.
Instead, they seek to leap
over the walls that separate
Jews from non-Jews and
reiterate faith in a better world
after the war is over.
And it also reminds us of something
that is very often forgotten,
that in the war, the USSR
for Jews in the East European ghettos
was in fact the only hope.
Great Britain had betrayed the Jews,
with the white paper
ending its promises to the Zionist
movement. This happened in
1939. The United States was
indifferent and
there was a natural desire
to think that the Red
Army would come in time to liberate
them. There was a natural hope that
Stalin, the great leader,
would emerge as the
only person in the world
who could defeat the Nazi war
machine.
You could argue that this
was engaging in illusions and
wishful thinking, but what other
choice did they have?
Now, Irene Shapiro herself
is an amazing woman.
Her family came from East Galicia,
which was a mixed Polish, Ukrainian,
and Jewish area.
But they moved to Grudziadz,
a town in northwestern Poland
near Gdansk, or Danzig,
and that's where she grew up.
It was a town with a large Jewish,
and it was a town with a large
German population where there were
very few Jews.
She did not grow up speaking Yiddish.
She grew up speaking Polish.
Her father was a respected music
teacher.
By all accounts, it was a very
happy family.
But with the rising tide of Nazism
among the local Germans, the
family pulled up stakes and
move to Bialystok in 1938.
Bialystok was a very different kind
of community.
It was a
city where the Jews were a majority
of the population, where the Jews spoke
mainly Yiddish.
But the family seems to have landed on its
feet. Her father was able to pick up
his career as a, a,
as a teacher.
And after a short German
occupation in September 1939,
Bialystok was taken
over by the Soviets
until June 1941
when the Germans invaded the Soviet
Union. And Irene Shapiro and
her parents and her sister found
themselves in the Bialystok ghetto.
The horrors of the German occupation
began literally the first
day that the Germans came.
Two thousand Jews were herded
into a synagogue and burned
alive. Thousands of Jewish
men were shanghaied off
the streets and shot.
After the first wave of terror
subsided,
a Bialystok ghetto was established,
which provided a period
of relative stability
until February 1943.
As ghettos go, the Bialystok
ghetto was not terrible.
The Judenrat enjoyed the
respect of most of the Jewish population.
It was led by an
engineer, Efraim Barasz,
who did the best he could to make
sure that people didn't starve, that they
didn't die of epidemics.
He set up many shops and enterprises,
and he deluded himself into thinking
that this work for the Germans
might buy time and save
the ghetto.
There was also a resistance movement
in the Bialystok ghetto led by Mordechaj
Tenenbaum, and
this resistance movement,
in fact, had
clear ties to
the Judenrat.
Barasz gave them money to buy weapons.
Barasz had frequent conversations
with Tenenbaum.
And
the Judenrat
simply asked the resistance movement
not to do anything that might
give the Germans an excuse to liquidate
the ghetto. And Irene Shapiro
was part of that resistance organization
and she was
determined to go to the forests
and fight as a partisan.
But before that happened, the Germans
pounced in August
1943, the second major
action in the Bialystok ghetto.
And without informing Barasz,
they began to deport all the Jews.
The resistance movement was taken totally
by surprise, and they were determined
to fight.
Now, when this happened,
it turned out that unlike
the Warsaw ghetto, where the Jews
supported the fighters, where the
Jews built seven hundred fifty
bunkers.
In fact, it was the civilian support
for the uprising in the Warsaw ghetto,
the hundreds of bunkers the Jews built,
which enabled the uprising to last for
30 days.
In Bialystok, none of this happened.
The young people
who were in the resistance were totally
isolated.
The Jews did not support
them.
They in fact believed
in German promises that they would
be sent to work.
And Irene Shapiro found herself
holding a grenade and not knowing
what to do with it.
And a German soldier actually comes
over, gently takes the
grenade from her hand and sends
her over to her mother and father,
who are waiting to be loaded onto a
train.
Some other young people fight back,
but within a day, the resistance
in the Bialystok ghetto was stamped out.
The train that the Germans put Irene
Shapiro's family on is divided
into two sections.
One section is
detached when the train comes
to Treblinka and the Jews there
are gassed.
In fact, this was the last killing in
Treblinka, in mid-August
1943, two weeks after the
uprising.
And once these Bialystok Jews were killed
and the camp was
dissolved, the cars
that Irene Shapiro
happened to be in went to Majdanek,
and Irene Shapiro and her
mother were separated from their father.
They were, they went through
all the horrors of Majdanek, but luckily
they were deported to another labor
camp before all the Jews in Majdanek
were killed in November
1943.
Irene Shapiro survived these
labor camps, lived to see the
liberation and then made
a life for herself in the United States
as a teacher in Bronx
High School of Science.
And she also had a family.
The, the song that she wrote
is written in Russian.
It's not written in Yiddish.
Yiddish was not Irene Shapiro's native
language, but Russian wasn't either.
And again, I think it shows this
desire, this, this
tendency to
put one's hopes in
the power of the Soviet
Union.
I want to end this
talk by saying that we should
judge this song not by
its literary or its musical
merit, because it doesn't have
a lot of literary merit.
And the song is simply the
kind of tune that you could hear
in any Soviet wartime movie.
But we should judge this song by another
criteria.
It's an example of spiritual
and cultural resistance, in the
widest sense of the term that
when the Germans try to crush you,
when the Germans try to reduce you
to a person without agency, without
hope, without initiative, singing
is one way to fight back,
to say no matter where I am
and no matter how terrible my situation
might be, I can still sing,
I can still write.
And that reminds me that
on one level, at least, I'm still
a human being.
Thank you.